Lyle Stephanie let me ask you first of
all what you made of the verdict last
night I think him deep down I thought it
was going to go that way obviously I had
no way of really knowing that bearing in
mind that was the initial decision which
is then acquitted and obviously
overturned and I think I said to people
at the time going into this we were well
aware that there would be a council
appear on the matter what last night's
decision was which is why you know I was
perhaps a bit nonplussed when the actual
decision came out and the other thing of
course for us is although stephanie has
some Italian language background wide
don't and in that courtroom it's
obviously a very tense it's read out
very quickly and it actually takes a few
seconds for for us or me personally to
even get a translation of what the
decision is so and Stephanie what do you
make of amanda knox saying already
there's no way I'm coming back to Italy
they'll have to drag me off kicking and
screaming and I think we're in a
difficult position at the moment because
there are so many steps in this system
that it's not been confirmed it's not
the end and as law said it could have
gone either way yesterday and I was
quite prepared for that especially
seeing as it will go to another level
again however without knowing what the
final answer is going to be it's
difficult to know how anyone's going to
feel or react and really when it comes
down to it if they are found guilty at
the very end of the case and she doesn't
come back here then that's going to be
for Italy and America to to kind of
decide what they're going to do do with
that because as love said previously if
they're convicted and they are guilty of
murder they need to be somewhere not
just free in America or Italy and so
must be difficult for you though this
has been going on the best part of seven
years now hmm and still it's not over
yeah
lately yeah I've said before that you
know the way that Meredith was killed is
obviously horrific would not really had
a chance to properly griefer because of
this whole process has been going on so
long there's also doing so much
attention on the defendants in the case
itself rather than Meredith is the
victim and yeah absolutely you know the
fact that it's in a foreign country a
lot of it's obviously in a foreign
language we're having to read
interpretations of stuff second hand and
on top about the fact that it's been
been as you say sort of knocking on in
seven years now and the next verdict in
this is going to be spring 2015 makes it
very difficult for sort of you know
finally draw a line under things and
move on meanwhile of course Meredith
Kercher your sister is almost forgotten
as you say in all of this it's all
become about Amanda not particularly if
she gets to see this what would you say
to her I don't know that we have
anything specific to say to anyone this
in question at the moment but in general
with regards to you saying about
Meredith being forgotten I think she has
been forgotten very much so in this case
because it does very much focus on the
trial rather than the victim at the
moment however there are a lot of people
out there who still send messages still
donate to the fund still talk about her
we're very much in touch with Meredith's
friends and as a family will remember
her together so she's definitely not
forgotten but i think that the focus has
been shifted in the case and in the
media forum actually as law said how
horrific this crime is what actually
happened to mez the fact she was only 21
and it could happen to someone else just
as easily I think that's almost the most
important part to remember that actually
we need to find out what happened you
seem very measured about this this was
your sister we have a woman who's been
convicted twice now her murder sitting
on the west coast of America saying I'm
not coming back I'm not going to serve
another day of this 28 and a half year
sentence
how's that made me feel well sorry
Augustus I am I thought I think part of
the reason we've we've tried to remain
measured about it as you say is because
I think we were made quite early on that
this could be a very lengthy process I
think as everyone has been following the
case and any of the details of is where
it's a very intricate complex firm case
and scenario of what perhaps happened
that night there's certainly a lot of a
lot of question marks I suppose at the
moment still over what precisely
happened and from our point of view you
know we very much supported the as I
said before the prosecution and the
legal team the songs they've taken on it
and the decision that they've made so
from our point of view while we're fully
supported on them and we're well aware
that it could have taken some time
decisions could have gone either way I'm
you know and it's it's difficult to sort
of 100-percent expect one thing to
happen or the other and I think you kind
of have to sort of sit almost them
across the middle of those two until
there is a final conclusion on it really
okay I ask you both a final question do
you think amanda knox and raffaele a
salacious to killed your sister I do you
think either of them will ever end up
back in jail I think that's a very
difficult question for us to answer at
the moment because as I said there are
still so many things being investigated
needing to be confirmed that we aren't
judges we're not jury and we're
certainly not detective so it's
difficult for us to know what's fact
what's fiction other than what we are
told and that is all that we can go by
it obviously suggests that that is the
truth and that they are guilty seeing as
it's been upheld again this time but
equally it was overturned last time so
we may never know exactly what's
happened but given the fact that the
Italian legal system is so thorough and
there is another stage we would hope
that they will be able to find out even
if not exactly what happened that night
just to be hundred percent sure who is
guilty
go to jail I thought I am you know also
lots been said at the moment of extra
dish you know if last night's decisions
upheld in spring 2015 as i said before i
be surprised if if America didn't
cooperate with an extradition you know
if ever mutual agreement on missin
America seek to extradite criminals from
other countries themselves I'd find it
strange if they didn't cooperate in that
sense and obviously selected to himself
being a natalia national already in the
country and then already had his
passport taken from him I don't I don't
see how you could have somebody
convicted of what as i said is such a
horrific crime we're not just talking of
you know a drunk driver here killing
somebody and I can't see how somebody
couldn't go to prison for that
you